cinéma avec la sortie sur les écrans du
journal de bridget jones le livre a
connu un succès international qui ignore
encore les déboires de cette jeune
héroïne célibataire qui raconte au
quotidien ses mésaventures une comédie
très réussie signée par les scénaristes
de quatre mariages et un enterrement ou
encore de coup de foudre à notting hill
une référence avec le retour évidemment
de hugh grant reportage marie-jo joie
j'ai décidé de prendre ma vie en main et
de commencer mon journal pour dire la
vérité sur bridget jones 5 millions de
lecteurs ou plutôt de lectrices se sont
retrouvés en cette charmante petite
boulotte trentenaire dont les deux
ambitions sont de perdre du poids est de
trouver le grand amour pour moi en
signant l'adaptation de son roman pour
le cinéma
helen fielding touche un point sensible
pourquoi malgré leur plus grande
autonomie
les femmes ont-elles toujours les mêmes
angoisses amoureuse ça à l'esprit
tchèque
la société exerce une pression constante
sur la femme en plus du succès elle doit
se trouver un homme fonder un foyer
cette pression est encore accentuée par
celle des parents des amis qui vous
disent que très bien tu vas voir un jour
tu vas rencontrer le bon j'ai deux
solutions renoncer et accepter ma
condition de vieille fille à perpétuité
pour finir dévoré par des bergers
allemands
oh non ce qui est très intéressant dans
le succès du journal de bridget jones
c'est que pour la première fois le mot
célibataire y remplace celui de vieille
fille c'est tellement ridicule de nos
jours de penser qu'une fille de 30 ans
est obligé de se marier pour être
heureuse
alors qu'elle peut avoir de bonnes
raisons de rester célibataire toute la
rai la liste les invités après coup de
foudre à notting hill
le voici pour la première fois dans un
rôle de beauce à nous et aux grandes
cool vérifie si l'image du héros
romantique
on va voir vers chez moi en tout bien
tout honneur pendant boys ça restera je
connais helen fielding depuis quelques
années et je lui racontais souvent mes
histoires de la nar
et quand j'ai lu le roman le héros
daniel cleaver réagi c'est exactement
comme moi dans certaines circonstances
il ya un peu de moi un passage plutôt
réussie de l'écrit à l'écran grâce à you
grande à l'aise dans la comédie comme un
poisson dans l'eau et renée zellweger
dont la performance va bien au delà des
kilos qu'elle a dû prendre pour le rôle